des écoliers transformer temporairement
en rats d'arts vivants mais en toute
sécurité une activité ludique pour
sensibiliser les automobilistes à
respecter les limites de vitesse et d'y
inclure artistes y en a 40 spots mais la
plupart ralentissent les élèves se
relaie pour participer à cette activité
qui est organisée par le service de
police de laval un élève tient le radar
dans sa main et et la vitesse des
automobilistes et retransmise sur le sac
à dos d'une autre écolières en verre et
bien les vitesses est conforme mais
attention en rouge elles dépassent les
limites moi je trouve que c'est du
bonbon c'est un plus lourd pour notre
école pour notre organisation aussi le
centre de service lancée la rentrée
septembre
c'est le temps de penser à la sécurité
autour des écoles pour la police de
laval l'opération est un succès on a des
bons impacts sont positifs les gens
ralentissent les parents également
qu'ils nous voient ça mais nous visiter
policière sur les lieux sur place donc
oui on peut considérer ça comme une
super vente efficace aucun constat
d'infraction n'a été mis par les
policiers qui voulaient juste se
rappeler aux automobilistes que la
vitesse permise dans les zones scolaires
est fixée à 30 kilomètres à l'heure
issigeac bissonnet radio-canada laval